hey hey man you're like ICP readings I
know a guy I know guy who woke you up
man
he could hook you up great it's me ha
the guy was me it was all a trick
hi everyone hi are ezel I hope these are
all well I'm just making this short
video just to say I'm still alive and I
still will be making SCP videos the only
problem with this is I'm not sure which
ones to make because there's so many
articles on that site I want to make
sure that I did good one night the last
video I did was the being impression
which was fun for me but quite a number
of the comments it felt like was videos
so I'm gonna do more because I got the
message loud and clear so so here's the
thing I can't be bothered going through
all my past videos I'm looking for
suggestions because I'm Lizzie so if you
wouldn't mind commenting underneath this
video with the SCP article you would
like to hear I will make a promise that
I will make the most thumbs Dopp
suggestion I think that's a good way to
do it because that way I know at least
two people want to see it and then that
means I'll do it and then that means
them people will be happy and because I
crave attention that means I'll be happy
as well so so everybody wins it's it's
one of them kind of scenarios so uh so
thank you everyone and I hope you have a
lovely day goodbye